Clock radios are a common consumer device which people can use without any
training and without normally making any mistakes. Never the less they
are complex, as the state chart we have produced indicates. In fact, the clock
radio that I have at home has a bug in it. If you get awakened by the radio,
turn it off and then change the alarm time to a later time. For example,
to waking your spouse, the radio comes back on. It still thinks that within,
that it is within the hour window. Okay I call that a bug and
I think that the original designers of the radio should have detected this
particular situation and change that implementation. In any case it is
only by carefully modeling and validation that such situations can be avoided.
State charts are a device that can help you do that careful thinking and
hopefully lead to better implementations, better understanding of
complex situations and ultimately better implementations of them.